the report during the Press was was
Grand so I was like which director is it
where he had this experience recently
with because I can't honestly you know
not to discuss it's definitely going to
sound this way it like it's hard to not
think is he talking about Tiger Woods it
is it just sounds like he is
[Music]
ladies and gentlemen Chris Hemsworth has
slammed Taiko YTD and Marvel he's sick
of their virtue signaling the two woke
the two works for me now for me I want
to give my hammer to a woman
let alone two women
my hammer to a woman no no no no no no
no no no no no no no no no no guys I've
been hearing all these headlines and I
was like well let's Deep dive this is
what we do we deconstruct what our
dramatic headlines and there you go is
this really dramatic this is as dramatic
as they want the clickbait to sound
let's see what's going on John how are
you I am I'm really nice today how are
you sir I'm doing okay it's been a wild
week that if you follow my Instagram
you'll know what's going on but anyway
guys leave a like that'd be very much
appreciated uh let's dive into this now
uh Chris Hemsworth he's been making the
rounds uh ever since his show Limitless
has come out it's a show where he uh
takes a pill gives him access to 100 of
his brain yeah he's been getting asked
of course about Thor because he's
Christmas Hemsworth and while there's a
kind of a lot of quotes to go from
there's there's two main paragraphs that
I think are the important ones to sort
of speak on because it's led to okay it
sounds like Chris Hemsworth is done with
I mean even in my interpretations he's
done with the goofy side of Thor not
necessarily he's done with the humor
because the humor's always been present
with Thor but maybe the goofier side and
did he throw shade at Taiko YTD that's
how some people have been interpreting
it and that one I do want to kind of
dive into because it I could see why
people if you let's just go into the
video all right the first quote that he
has here I think this is the one from
the Josh Horowitz show the podcast guy
who gets all the greatest interviews in
the world he says you look at Thor one
and two they were quite similar he
smoking this Thor Cadence told time
Ragnarok and love and thunder are
similar I think it's about Reinventing
it and obviously being asked about if he
would come back for Thor I've had such a
unique opportunity with infinity war and
end game to do very drastic things with
the character I enjoy that I like
keeping bit of people on their toes
you're an Italian it keeps me on my toes
it keeps me invested I've said this
before but when it becomes too familiar
I think there's a risk in getting lazy
then because I know what I'm doing I
don't know if I'm even invited back but
if I was I think would have to be a
drastically different version in tone
everything just for my own sanity he
laughs
Thor lost his mind that last one he's
gotta figure it out now so yeah
immediately the main thing you might be
hearing people talking about is he's
saying drastic changes drastic changes
and then when he elaborates on the quote
you know what's saying like tone and
everything like okay yeah it does sound
like it went like progressively goofier
with Thor love and thunder in terms of
the interpretation of Thor so yeah I
would liken to say that he would not
want to return for that to me and I
think a lot of people probably feel this
way arguably the best interpretation
that had the perfect Middle Ground of
Thor was actually an Infinity War
because he's the God of Thunder he's a
God and he was badass in that movie he
was awesome he was Regal but he was also
funny and he was the right blend and
that was immediately following Thor
Ragnarok when they reinvented him to be
more funny and he had the perfect mix
not that he he can't just go back to
that because he wants to do something
very different so I don't know what that
different would entail but well I feel
like you could almost use this as the
opportunity to go back and maybe nail
some of the tones that they didn't
before because I feel like with the
first two Thor movies they are similar
they are going for a more Shakespearean
a more epic grandiose yeah bring back
the blonde eyebrows that's right
cut it short those were going for a tone
that I think the first one at least
people agree kind of hit and the second
one people seem to agree didn't hit
quite as well and I feel like yeah we
pivoted to Comedy we discovered Chris
Hemsworth has such a great comedic tone
and timing and I feel like now could be
an interesting time to yeah bring the
humor back down to just aspects of the
character and maybe really nailed that
epic quality that Epic Fantasy tone that
they've always wanted to and Go full
fantasy with it you know true I think
that's actually a good call you should
hire you to direct I am the new Kevin
just from that people assume that it
doesn't sound like this would be the
Taiko YTD person who direct that
drastically different tone right sure
immediately they're like okay it sounds
like he wouldn't want to return of Taiko
ytd's coming back but then here's the
quote that he's not citing Taiko YTD
here uh yet people uh have interpreted
it and then even John and I were like
let's just go to Chris Hemsworth IMDb
and see if there's like something here
that we could maybe pinpoint a little
bit because I'm trying to figure it out
it could be actually this director it's
time to play who's he talking about yeah
I mean he's got these repeating
experiences with extraction so it's
probably not that director I mean Andrew
Goddard with uh bad times yeah it's the
Russo Brothers
uh yeah so here's what this quote is
basically he's saying I'm just the point
of my life where I'm meeting with
different directors and people say oh
yeah look he imaginious he mad while
he's a genius he'll Mark great films and
I'm like is that who I want to spend
more days with uh four months five
months of shooting there you got press
and possible reshoots and so on and he
went out to praise George Miller because
he's uh in the Mad Max or the furiosa
prequel film and uh he was like we're
talking about George Miller
yeah and then when you're hearing stuff
like talking about these eccentricities
and then dealing with someone like this
for so long and when you think of the
directors he's worked with some of the
most eccentric with the most definitive
idiosyncrasies would probably be Taiko
YTD Michael man it's got to be Michael
Mass but I never worked with him again I
hate working with this guy too many
retakes
one and done Chris that's me because a
lot of the films he's done he's worked
with them several times and it's sort of
like the Mad genius and I don't know
he's he's collaborated now uh with taika
it looks like on three things he was on
that James and the Giant Peach and taika
and friends thing they seem like the
reporter in the Press was was Grand so I
was like which which director is it
where he had this experience recently
with because I can't is it like and
honestly you know not to discuss it's
definitely going to sound this way it
like it's hard to not think is he
talking about Tiger Woods it is it just
sounds like he is especially when you
look at the other quote like he's
talking about yeah because it's that
thing of you look at the personality and
taika has a big personality and if you
look at the Thor love and thunder press
tour it seemed like he was at least
establishing a tone that didn't rub
everybody the right way that could then
suggest that yeah maybe on set taika has
his own atmosphere and it's your job to
kind of adapt to it rather than being
like a full-on collaborative presence or
something like that but then again I
don't know it does seem like in the past
they've gotten along famously but it
could also too be something of a middle
ground you know maybe there's a lacking
Nuance where it's like yes maybe he and
taika are friends but maybe taika's
style after two of the most expensive
and high production value movies you
know of his career maybe he's yeah
realizing I would rather work with
filmmakers who established a set that is
kind and inclusive and a fun place to
spend your time and I mean you know for
the below the line and for the less you
know flashy jobs they often say like one
of the best assets you could have is
just being Pleasant on set you know well
it sounds to me like tiger YTD I mean
with regardless of this quote I feel
like taco it like even though he has
said he'll return I think of something
along the lines of Chris Hemsworth uh
want some too or something like that but
I imagine that with the way Chris
Hemsworth seems to operate and I love
how he's taking this character of Thor
and has become sort of this actor who
does look at the directors he wants to
work with you know he's that leading man
status now where he can go it's this
director so I want to work with him
because of this kind of guy he's not a
movie star he's not a movie star though
yeah let's not forget those words and
I'm working with Terrence so I feel like
he might be in a position where he semi
chooses who that next director is sure
he has a say and who that next director
might be which would be pretty cool
um and I'd be I'd be down to see who he
picks Ron Howard they've worked together
twice already make it happen again
that's the one that's just the Mad
genius he's sick of the director of Men
In Black International
that was uh oh my gosh I did Friday and
and oh really and uh gray F Gary gray
did a minute black International that's
who he's talking about I think so crazy
ass Gary gray wow in that Authority
though to choose the next director
pretty much like the way some of these
headlines make it sound is that it's uh
oh my God like no I have demands but I
don't know it sounds like casual about
it yeah all of Chris Hemsworth news
lately has had that quality where the
the headlines are like oh man Chris is
upset oh no wait he's actually pretty
thoughtful about this he's just kind of
Taken life because of Alzheimer's
disease yeah he's like no he's just
aware that he can be so susceptible yeah
I gotta be a little cautious and it also
just takes some time for all the dust to
settle I mean Thor 11 Thunder is pretty
fresh so you know we'll see but I feel
like too you know after two installments
of taika I don't think anybody would be
heartbroken to see a fresh take you know
he certainly left his Mark and I think
taika's Mark will endure regardless and
I think that it should be like Chris
Hemsworth has talked about that he would
want it to be the final one if he does
return and I think it should be the
final one like I think there's a way to
close out Chris Hemsworth's Journey with
the character where you do finalize that
Arc and I wouldn't want love and thunder
to be his last performance
um I think it would be I mean obviously
probably being like Secret Wars or some
[ __ ] but I feel like for like a solo
Thor film I would love to see that Arc
really come full circle where it does go
back to being more of the Gaga of
thunder and where he reaches a true
maturity as a character I think is is
something that we could see that's new
yeah yeah that'd be awesome all right
guys well what do you think about this
story leave your thoughts down below uh
be sure to subscribe leave a like click
that Bell and let's end this with a
patreon
Brian Perry Brian Brad Perry you've been
a patron of ours for 12 months exactly
welcome to your one year anniversary for
being part of our patreon page not many
people get to say they can do that and
uh you're one of the few so thank you so
much for being here for a full year I
hope the year has been rewarding I hope
you've enjoyed what we've had to offer
and I just want to say I just hit my
chest way too hard
uh thank you for being a part of of our
lives in such a meaningful way so say
this and but I when I say to the patrons
especially their support means the world
I really mean that because uh you guys
are absolutely incredible special to us
and so thank you Brian for being part of
that category let's select a few much
love to you brother and I hope that uh
fun times are happening in Liverpool
those are Liverpool
[Music]
right
[Music]
[Music]